[Music]
hi it's Michele from lab life and beauty
science chemistry PhD and SAN of
research-based skincare products if you
follow me on instagram you might have
seen that earlier this year I got to
show a biochemist facilities in France I
got to access 19 tons of questions and
take lots of notes today I'm going to be
talking about some of the products and
by dermis sebum range and this video is
produced in partnership with by Gemma if
you've been following me for a while
you'll know that I've used lots of
Bioderma products in the past and I've
reviewed a lot of their products on my
blog as well I think the earliest one
would have been in 2013 which is six to
seven years ago so a bit of background a
Bioderma and why I've been into them for
so long by Gemma a very sized focus
French dramatic asthmatic brand and
unlike a lot of other brands that mostly
based their products around science
patch ingredients by jomega a few steps
further and they actually drew their own
original research and they do this in
conjunction with universities and
dermatologists and other experts if you
look up Bioderma
on a journal database like Google
Scholar or PubMed you'll see some of
their publications in some pretty
prestigious journals like the Journal of
the American Academy of Dermatology the
European Journal of Dermatology and the
Journal of cosmetic dermatology their
main specialties and research are acne
sensitive skin and sunscreens and this
is reflected in a lot of their really
innovative products which I've talked
about before so for example they
invented my cell water and the astrodome
range is recommended by dermatologists
and the eczema Association of Australia
if you're interested in more
behind-the-scenes info on how they
develop manufacture and test their
products I have a blog post all about
that like I said before by derma
RA derma cosmetic brand there's a
tradition in France where if you have a
skin problem you go to a para pharmacy
and in the para pharmacy you talk to a
pharmacist about what problems you have
and they'll recommend you the right skin
care products from one of these derma
cosmetic brands which are usually
formulated with the science behind how
skin works in mind and if you've ever
been to a French para pharmacy you'll
know why this process is important
because there are a lot of products it
can be pretty overwhelming so today I'm
going to try to help you out if you've
ever looked at the CBM range and
which product is right for you then I'm
going to be doing a deep dive on each of
them
now you mostly hear about acne in the
context of like teenage skin but adult
acne is a growing problem adult acne is
when you have acne it over the age of 25
and it's estimated that up to about 40
percent of adult women have this problem
the same four factors lead to both
adolescent acne and adult acne they are
overproduction of sebum which is skin
oil clogged pores overgrowth of acne
bacteria and also inflammation acne
treatments will target one or more of
these four factors the problem is a lot
of these acne treatments are quite harsh
they tend to be Kurata lytic which means
that they increase how quickly your skin
sheds and so if your skin is shedding
much faster that can lead to sensitivity
and dryness and harshness the sebum
range has three main aims firstly it
tries to help your skin prevent further
acne by using very gentle actives
secondly it helps your skin repair its
own barrier functions so that it's more
resilient and so it's less sensitive and
thirdly it tries to counteract the
effect of these harsh medicated actives
that you might be using by hydrating
your skin there are a few patient
ingredient blends that Bioderma has put
into the CBM range a lot of Bioderma
products including this whole sebum
range contain a group of five
ingredients known as DAF and these help
make skin more resilient so reduces skin
reactivity reduces the permeability of
the skin and it reduces free radicals in
some of the moisturizers there's the
fluid active complex which helps
decrease the even levels and regulate
the quality of sebum so people have acne
tend to have more squalene in their
sebum and this can oxidize and when it
does it leads to clogged pores as well
as irritation fluid active contains
antioxidants which have been shown to
decrease the oxidation of squalene
Bioderma have lots of clinical trials to
back these up and I'm going to link the
patients in the description if you're
interested in reading a bit more so on
to the sebum range today I'm going to be
talking about five products there are
two cleansers two moisturizers and one
moisturizing makeup primer so the first
product is the CBM pastry micelle water
I've talked about these micellar waters
before and how they work so what's
special about the CBM my soul water well
it contains act
that acts to help with acne firstly it
contains Lincoln copper and copper is
the reason why it has this blue color
copper is mostly antibacterial and it's
the reason why you shouldn't use this
around your eyes because it can sting
your eyes there are a few studies that
suggest such link might help with acne
so it might decrease sebum levels it's
antioxidant and it might also help
reduce the acne bacteria as well the way
you use it is you pour it onto a cotton
pad and then wipe it over your face so
one of the questions I get a lot about
my soul water is is it okay to leave it
on your skin because as you guys might
know if you've heard me talk about this
in the past surfactants are often
irritating and the answer is it really
depends on the micellar water and what
ingredients they use especially the
surfactant so for Bioderma all of them
ingredients and their micellar water are
also found and levon products including
the surfactant so they're fine to leave
on your skin you can still rinse it off
if you want but that does mean that
you're getting rid of the benefits of
the rest of the ingredients in the
micellar water there's also the fact
that in bio drummers micellar waters
they actually use something called ppi
water which is water thats so pure that
it's fine for injection so if you're in
an area where the water is maybe a bit
hard or maybe not entirely clean then
it's probably beneficial to not rinse it
off and just not contaminate your face
with that extra water I've been finding
the micellar water really really good
for when I'm in a rush when I don't have
time or the opportunity to wash my face
like on the plane or after going to the
gym the other cleanser in the range is
the sebum gel which is a wash off
foaming cleanser it has gentle
surfactants it's got sodium cocoa and
for acetate and sodium laureth sulfate
having a combination of surfactants
makes cleanse them more gentle it also
contains lots of humectants which keep
your skin hydrated and so it doesn't
feel tight or stripped after you finish
cleansing now I know a lot of people are
against foaming cleansers and I think
the reason for this is that a lot of
older foaming cleansers tend to be quite
harsh and stripping but newer foaming
cleansers if they're designed properly
they don't have this problem so they are
designed to be gentler to your skin and
so they don't necessarily strip your
skin more than a non foaming cleanser
I've been using this gel cleanser for a
few weeks now and I like that at least
my skin feeling really plump and hydrate
I've also been using it on my back
because I do get a little bit of back
knee as well it can also be used as a
shaving gel if you want on to the
moisturizers so both of these
moisturizers contain lots and lots of
glycerin which as you might know is my
favorite you met it and it's over here
you met your moisturizers help hold
moisture onto your skin surface and
they're not oil base which means that
for oily skin like mine they tend to be
really nice glycerin is a particularly
special humectant waste riser because
firstly it's already in your skin
secondly it works on something called
aquaporins which is water channels in
your skin and it's also been found that
it doesn't dehydrate your skin even
without putting anything else on top so
firstly I have the sium sensitive this
is particularly special because it's
designed for acne prone skin but it
doesn't have any character lytic action
which means it doesn't increase your
skin turnover so this means it's really
good for sensitive acne prone skin where
you're already using something that's
character lytic so things like rationale
it's like Italian or threatenin above
nor point not to 5% and you're seeing a
bit of dryness and peeling and
irritation I really like this because
it's really hydrating but it's still
mattifying so it's really good for
daytime use it's called 20% glycerin and
it claims to give 12 hour hydration
what's also cool about this is that it
contains Seabury stool which is where
they've combined the fluid active with
the Cuchillo which you might know is a
trending ingredient what's quite
interesting is that by Joma did a
clinical trial and I found that say
barest or made other changes to the
sebum composition as well so after 2
months of using it twice daily they
found that there was an increase in
antibacterial lauric and Safie any acid
and also an increase in linoleic acid as
well there's also a decrease in oleic
acid and so generally what this means is
that you have better save on quality
that doesn't clump as much as well as a
bear so it also contains infla straw
which blocks inflammatory messengers in
the skin and so what this means is it
reduces acne and it can also reduce post
inflammatory hyperpigmentation this is
the brown spots that you get after the
acne goes the sensitive is also really
soothing it hydrates and restores the
skin barrier and it actually has been
found to reduce the side effects of
medication so things like redness
dryness itching and burning sensations
so this one has a really light and
mattifying texture but if you're often
mattifying there is a product which I'm
going to talk about a little bit later
which might be even better for you now
if you're using even stronger acne
medication like isotretinoin which is in
Roaccutane this is an old medication
that you take then you might be more
interested in the CBM Hydra this is the
most hydrating of the moisturizers and
it really targets skin that has red
patches and lots of flaking again it's
got lots of humectant glycerin it's also
got ceramides as well as some mineral
oil and mineral oil even though there's
a lot of rumors that it's comedogenic
it's actually not and it's actually one
of the best oils for acne prone skin
because it's very bland
it's also very stable so it doesn't
oxidize or change on you
there's also Allentown and an ox loan
which sooth your skin and reduce redness
personally I like using the sensitive
during the day under makeup and I use
the Hydra at night even though I'm not
using ice attrition on my skin is really
dehydrated prone and it's winter so I
really appreciate the extra hydration
the final product I'm talking about
today is the sebum map control this is a
really great product if you have oily
skin and you want to control the shine
but you also want some skincare benefits
as well so it has a lot of the
ingredients that are in the rest of the
range it's got glycerin it has the fluid
active it has zinc as well it's also got
salicylic acid which is exfoliating and
reduces the pore size it's also got
mushroom extract which contains a
garrick acid which again reduces the
appearance of your pore size like a lot
of other makeup primers it's also got
mattifying and blurring ingredients and
so it has that immediate blurring effect
but it also has a longer-term effect as
well because this is so mattifying it's
best if you use it just on the oily
areas so for me that's the t-zone as
well as these bits here so I hope this
was an informative deep dive on these
products and it helps you work out which
products are best for your skin let me
know what other brands you want me to
look at in the future as well if you
enjoyed this video you can also check
out the rest of my videos and like and
subscribe to my channel you can also
follow me on Instagram and Facebook and
check out my blog as well see you next
time